y las imágenes se oscurecen.
¿Qué haría si tuviera yo a Hitler ante mí?
No es difícil imaginarlo si me esfuerzo.
Le rompería la espalda y el cuello,
le sacaría los ojos con un instrumento puntiagudo.
Le reventaría los tímpanos. Le cortaría la lengua.
Lo dejaría vivo en un respirador artificial,
alimentado por tubos, sin poder hablar o moverse o ver o oír, solo sentir,
y luego le inyectaría algo canceroso
para que se pudriera,
para que cada célula en su cuerpo gritara agónicamente,
para que cada segundo lo sintiera como una eternidad en el infierno.
Eso es lo que le haría a Hitler.
He tenido esta fantasía desde niño
y ahora todavía de vez en cuando.
Y cuando la tengo, mi corazón se altera.
Esos, mis planes contra el alma más malvada de la historia...
Pero hay un problema,
es que realmente no creo en el alma o en el mal,
y "malvado" es el título de un musical.
Pero hay gente que me gustaría ver muerta,
pero no creo en la pena de muerte.
Pero me gustan las películas violentas,
pero defiendo el control estricto de armas.
Una vez estuve en la web del juego "Laser tag"
y me divertí mucho escondido en una esquina disparando a la gente.
Es decir, soy el típico humano confundido en cuanto a la violencia.
Como especie, obviamente tenemos problemas de violencia.
Usamos duchas de gas para envenenar,
cartas con ántrax, aviones como armas,
la violación en masa como estrategia militar.
Somos una especie miserablemente violenta.
Pero hay una complicación,
no odiamos la violencia.
Odiamos la violencia del tipo malo,
y cuando la ejerce el buen tipo,
la alentamos, la condecoramos,
votamos por ella, nos unimos a sus defensores.
Cuando es la violencia correcta,
nos encanta.
Y hay otra complicación,
además de ser una especie miserablemente violenta,
también somos extraordinariamente altruistas, compasivos.
¿Cómo da la biología respuesta a nuestro mejor comportamiento
a nuestro peor comportamiento y a las ambigüedades entre ambos?
Para empezar,
lo totalmente aburrido es entender las partes motoras de nuestra conducta.
Tu cerebro ordena a tu médula espinal, a tus músculos
que haga una cosa u otra,
y sí, bien, lo haces.
Lo que es difícil de entender es el significado del comportamiento,
porque en algunos casos, apretar el gatillo es un acto terrible;
en otros, es un sacrificio heroico.
En algunos casos, darle la mano a otro es
misericordioso,
en otros, una profunda traición.
El desafío es entender
la biología de nuestros actos en contexto,
y eso es muy difícil.
Una cosa que está clara, es que no se llega a nada
si piensan que hay una región cerebral u hormona
o gen o experiencia infantil
o un mecanismo evolutivo que explique todo.
Al contrario, cada pequeño acto tiene niveles múltiples de causalidad.
Veamos un ejemplo.
Uno tiene una pistola.
Hay una crisis:
tumultos, violencia, gente corriendo.
Un extraño está corriendo hacia ti y en un estado agitado
no puedes ver si la expresión es de miedo, amenazadora, furiosa,
pero tiene algo en la mano que parece una pistola.
No estás seguro.
El extraño viene corriendo hacia ti
y tú aprietas el gatillo.
Y resulta que la cosa en la mano de la persona
era un celular.
Así que planteamos esta pregunta biológica:
¿qué pasó para causar esta acción?
¿que causó el comportamiento?
Y esto es una multitud de preguntas.
Empezamos.
¿Qué pasaba en tu cerebro
un segundo antes de apretar el gatillo?
Y esto nos lleva a una región cerebral llamada amígdala.
La amígdala, que es central en la violencia,
central en el miedo, inicia descargas en cascada
que tienen como consecuencia apretar el gatillo.
¿Cuál era el nivel de actividad en tu amígdala un segundo antes?
Pero para comprender esto tenemos que retroceder un poquito.
¿Qué pasaba en el ambiente segundos minutos antes
de impactar en la amígdala?
Ahora, obviamente, las escenas, los sonidos de tumultuo,
eso fue pertinente.
Pero encima,
es más posible que confundas un celular con una pistola
si el desconocido es hombre,
voluminoso y de otra raza.
Aún más, si tienes dolores,
si estás con hambre, si estás agotado,
tu córtex frontal no va a funcionar tan bien,
la parte del cerebro que tiene que llegar a la amígdala a tiempo
para preguntar: "¿Estás seguro de que es una pistola?
Pero debemos retroceder un paso.
Ahora tenemos que examinar las horas o días anteriores,
y así, llegamos al ámbito de las hormonas.
Por ejemplo, la testosterona,
donde sin importar tu sexo,
si tus niveles de testosterona en la sangre son elevados,
es más probable pensar que una cara con expresión neutra
parece amenazadora.
Niveles altos de testosterona, niveles altos de hormonas del estrés,
causan que tu amígdala esté más activa
y que tu córtex frontal sea más lento.
Retrocediendo aún más, semanas y meses atrás,
¿cuál es la relación aquí?
Se trata del ámbito de la plasticidad cerebral,
el hecho de que el cerebro puede cambiar como resultado de experiencias
y si los meses pasados han estado llenos de estrés y traumas,
tu amígdala se ha agrandado.
Las neuronas están más irritables,
mientras que tu córtex frontal se ha atrofiado.
Todo es significativo para lo que pasa en ese segundo.
Pero retrocedamos aún más, años atrás,
por ejemplo, a la adolescencia.
El hecho principal central del cerebro adolescente
es que está trabajando a toda potencia,
excepto en el córtex frontal,
que todavía está a media marcha,
éste no madura completamente hasta tener más o menos 25.
Y por eso, la adolescencia y la juventud
son los años en que el ambiente y la experiencia moldean tu córtex frontal
aquel que tendrás como adulto en ese momento crítico.
Pero retrocediendo aún más,
retrocediendo a la niñez y a la vida fetal
y a todas las versiones diferentes que podrían existir,
obviamente, esa es la época en que tu cerebro se está formando,
y es importante.
Pero además, la experiencia en esos momentos
produce lo que se llama cambios epigenéticos,
en algunos casos permanentes,
activando permanentemente ciertos genes, apagando otros.
Y como ejemplo de esto,
si un feto está expuesto a muchas hormonas del estrés a través de la madre,
la epigenética hará que la amígdala adulta
sea más irritable,
y uno tenga niveles más altos de hormonas del estrés.
Pero retrocedamos aún más,
cuando uno es solo un feto,
solo una colección de genes.
Los genes son muy importantes para todo esto,
pero de manera crítica, los genes no determinan nada,
porque los genes funcionan diferentemente en ambientes diferentes.
Un ejemplo clave aquí:
hay una variante de gen llamado MAO-A
y si uno tiene esa variante,
tiene mucha mayor probabilidad de cometer violencia antisocial
solo, si uno ha sufrido abusados en la niñez.
Los genes y el ambiente interactúan,
y lo que está pasando un segundo antes de apretar el gatillo
refleja una vida entera de interacciones entre esos genes y el ambiente.
Sorprendentemente, tenemos que retroceder aún más,
retroceder siglos,
¿qué hacían tus antepasados?
Si por ejemplo, eran pastores nómadas,
eran pastores,
gente viviendo en el desierto o las llanuras
con sus rebaños de camellos, vacas, cabras,
existen posibilidades de que hubieran inventado una cultura de honor,
llena de clases guerreras,
violencia retributiva, venganzas de clan,
e increíblemente, siglos después,
eso influirá en los valores con los que te educaron.
Pero tenemos que retroceder más,
millones de años,
porque si hablamos de genes,
implícitamente hablamos de la evolución de los genes.
Y lo que se ve, por ejemplo,
son patrones en diferentes especies de primates.
Algunas han evolucionado a niveles muy bajos de agresión,
otras han evolucionado en la dirección opuesta,
y flotando entre ellas por dónde se mire, están los humanos.
Otra vez esta especie confundida y casi no definida
que tiene todo el potencial de ir en una dirección u otra.
Y, ¿adónde hemos llegado?
Básicamente, lo que vemos es,
si queremos entender un comportamiento,
ya bien repugnante, maravilloso
o confusamente equidistante,
si queremos comprender,
debemos tomar en cuenta lo que pasó desde un segundo antes
hasta un millón de años atrás
y todo el tiempo entre ese intervalo.
Y, ¿a qué conclusión podemos llegar en este punto?
Oficialmente, es complicado.
¡Uy, qué útil es realmente eso!
Es complicado,
y mejor tener mucho cuidado, mucha precaución,
antes de concluir que sabes qué causa un comportamiento,
especialmente si es un acto que uno está juzgando duramente.
Para mí, el punto más importante de todo esto
tiene que ver con cambio.
Cada pedazo de biología que he mencionado aquí,
puede cambiar en circunstancias diferentes.
Por ejemplo, los ecosistemas cambian.
Hace miles de años, el Sahara era una pradera exuberante.
Las culturas cambian.
En el siglo XVII
el pueblo más aterrador en Europa era el sueco,
arrasando con todo.
Esto es lo que hacen los militares suecos ahora.
No han tenido una guerra en 200 años.
Más importante, los cerebros cambian.
Las neuronas crean nuevos procesos.
Los circuitos se desconectan.
Todo en el cerebro cambia
y esto genera ejemplos extraordinarios
de cambio humano.
Primero:
Este es un hombre llamado John Newton,
un señor teólogo británico
que juega un rol central en la abolición de la esclavitud del Imperio Británico
a principios del siglo XIX.
Sorprendentemente, este hombre se pasa décadas de joven
como capitán de un barco de esclavos,
y luego como inversor en el comercio de esclavos,
se hizo rico.
Y de pronto algo cambió,
algo cambió en él,
algo que el mismo Newton celebraba en lo que lo hace más famoso,
un himno que escribió:
"Amazing Grace".
Este otro es un hombre llamado Zenji Abe en la mañana del 6 de diciembre de 1941,
a punto de dirigir un escuadrón japonés de bombarderos a atacar Pearl Harbor.
Este mismo hombre 50 años después
abrazando a un superviviente del ataque
Y en la vejez,
Zenji Abe se presentó a un grupo de supervivientes
en una ceremonia en Pearl Harbor
y en inglés titubeante pidió disculpas por lo que había hecho de joven.
No siempre requiere décadas.
A veces, cambios extraordinarios pueden pasar en solo horas.
Consideren la tregua de paz en Navidad de la 1ª Guerra Mundial en 1914.
Los poderes gobernantes negociaron una corta tregua
para que los soldados salieran,
recogieran los cuerpos de las trincheras.
Y de pronto los soldados británicos y alemanes
estaban haciendo eso,
y ayudándose los unos a los otros a cargar muertos,
y luego ayudándose a escavar tumbas en la tierra congelada,
rezando juntos
y pasando la Navidad juntos intercambiando regalos.
Y al día siguiente, jugando fútbol juntos
e intercambiando direcciones para encontrarse tras la guerra.
Esa tregua siguió hasta que los oficiales llegaron
y dijeron: "Les dispararemos si no regresan a pelear entre Uds.."
Y todo lo de aquí fueron unas horas
para que estos hombres crearan una nueva categoría de "nosotros",
todos nosotros acá en las trincheras
en los dos lados, muriendo sin razón,
y quienes los "ellos" son poderes anónimos tras las lineas
que los usaban como títeres.
A veces los cambios ocurren en segundos.
Probablemente el evento más horroroso de la guerra en Vietnam
fue la masacre de My Lai.
Una brigada de soldados estadounidenses
entró a un pueblo indefenso lleno de civiles
y mató entre 350 y 500 de ellos,
violó en masa a mujeres y niños,
mutiló cuerpos.
Fue horroroso.
Horroroso porque ocurrió, porque el gobierno lo negó,
porque el gobierno estadounidense, no hizo más que frotarse las manos,
y horroroso porque seguro no fue el único caso.
Este hombre, Hugh Thompson, este es el hombre que paró la masacre de My Lai.
Estaba pilotando un helicóptero de combate,
aterrizó, se bajó
y vio a los soldados disparando a bebes
disparando a ancianas,
se dio cuenta de lo que pasaba,
y tomó su helicóptero
e hizo algo que cambió su vida entera
de quién es "nosotros" y quién "ellos."
Aterrizó su helicóptero
entre algunos sobrevivientes del pueblo y los soldados estadounidenses
y apuntó sus metralletas hacia sus compañeros estadounidenses,
y les dijo: "si no paran de matar los voy a acribillar."
Esta gente no es más especial que ninguno de nosotros.
Las mismas neuronas, los mismos neuroquímicos,
la misma biología.
Lo que nos queda es el cliché inevitable:
"Aquellos que no estudian la historia están destinados a repetirla."
Lo que tenemos acá es lo opuesto a eso.
Aquellos que no estudian la historia de cambios humanos extraordinarios,
aquellos que no estudian la biología de lo que nos puede transformar
de nuestras peores a nuestras mejores acciones,
los que no hacen esto están destinados a no poder
repetir estos momentos incandescentes, magníficos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
CA: Charlas que realmente te dan un modelo mental sobre algo,
esas son mis charlas TED favoritas,
y acabamos de escuchar una.
Robert, muchísimas gracias por eso. Buena suerte con el libro.
Fascinante.
Intentaremos traerte aquí en persona algún año.
Muchísimas gracias.
RS: Gracias. Gracias a todos.